in this video we're going to go through
three examples finding the area of a
regular polygon we're going to do one
where you're given the side length we're
going to do one where you're given the
radius and we're going to be given one
where you're given the apothem so before
we dive into these three examples let's
talk about the formulas that we're going
to be using we're either going to be
using this formula one-half the apothem
times the perimeter of the regular
polygon or we're going to do one half
the apothem times the number of sides
times the length of a side so just so
you can understand a little bit better
these formulas in case you forget you
can easily quickly figure out the area
whenever you have a regular polygon what
makes it regular is that all the
interior angles are the same and all the
side lengths are the same and so what
happens is if you subdivide this into
triangles each one of these triangles is
going to have the same area so what you
do is you drop an altitude which
represents the height of one of those
triangles and you say well let me find
the area of this triangle right here at
the bottom that's going to be one half
the base of the triangle which we're
going to call S here the side length
times the height of the triangle which
in this case is referred to as the
apothem
and once you find the area of that
triangle if you multiply by n the number
of triangles that's going to give you
the area of the entire polygon now you
can see this formula here multiplication
is commutative you can change the order
you're going to get this formula
and if you recognize that the side
length Okay times the number of side
lengths that's actually equal to the
perimeter and so that's how we're
getting one half apothem times perimeter
this formula right here so again if you
ever forget just find the area of one
triangle multiply by how many triangles
you have so let's dive into the first
example and I want to show you how to do
this a regular hexagon that has a side
length of 10 centimeters that's all
we're given how do we find the area
well go ahead and pause the video see if
you can do this one on your own but if I
was going to do it what I would do is I
would find the center of that polygon
and I would subdivide it into triangles
like I was showing you earlier over here
and
what we have here is what's called a
central angle and that central angle if
you think about this this is like a
circle which is 360 degrees but if we
divide that by these six angles here at
the center 360 divided by 6 is 60
degrees and so let's label that 60 and
then if we drop an altitude
okay which represents the height of this
triangle what happens is it's going to
bisect this central angle which is going
to make this a 30 degree angle for each
of these triangles and when you drop
that altitude which we call the apothem
it's also going to bisect the base or
cut that base in half so each of these
guys is going to be 5. so let's take a
look at this triangle now you can see
it's a 30 60 90 triangle because all the
angles in a triangle add up to 180 this
is a special right triangle so let's
just draw that a little bit larger over
here so we can see it
30 60 90. this is 5 and this is our
possum and we want to figure out what
this side is here now you probably
remember from
earlier in math this is called X this
side here is called x square root of 3
and the one across from the right angle
that's 2x these are the ratios that we
see in a 30-60-90 triangle so if we're
given this side here the short leg 5 to
get to this longer leg this x root 3
side we have to multiply by the square
root of 3. so that means that a here is
going to be 5 root 3.
now I'll show you how to do this using a
trigonometry and sine cosine tangent
ratios but let's just set this up first
so we're going to use this formula one
half a possum times the perimeter so we
have one half
the apothem which is the height of this
triangle right here we say this 5 root 3
times the perimeter now that's going to
be 10 times 6 sides so that gives us a
perimeter of 60.
and if we multiply that together let's
see a half times 60 is 30 times 5 is 150
square root of 3. so 150
square root of 3 centimeters squared
that's the area now let me show you how
to do it if you didn't know how to use
the 30 60 90 triangles what you can do
is you can position yourself here at
this angle 30 degrees and you can say
what trig function ties together the
opposite side 5 and this adjacent side a
which let's just say we don't know well
let's see opposite and adjacent that's
tangent so what we can do here is we can
say the tangent of 30 degrees is equal
to opposite 5 over adjacent a
now we can cross multiply and solve or
there's a property of proportions that
allows us to Interchange these on the
diagonal so this would be a over one
uh which is a is equal to 5 divided by
the tangent of 30 degrees and then what
we can do that we can put in place of
our apothem right here 5 root 3. the
only thing is when you do it this way
you're going to get like a decimal
approximation instead of like an exact
answer so depending on what the problem
is asking for exact answer or rounded
answer you can do it either one of those
ways so let's dive into the next example
okay for example number two now see if
you can do this one it's a regular
pentagon with an apothem of four inches
so let's go ahead and do the technique
of dividing this up into
congruent triangles
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to drop an altitude of one of
these triangles I usually like to do
this one at the bottom and that's what's
called the apothem right here so this is
a is equal to four inches
okay so now we're going to do is we need
to figure out what the perimeter is we
have the apothem but we don't have the
perimeter so
first thing I like to do is figure out
what is the central angle here again we
said this is a circle 360 degrees but
you can see that we have five triangles
so 360 divided by 5 is 72 degrees but
then when we drop that altitude half of
72 is going to give us 36 degrees
so that's the key is to find that
central angle and then cut it in half
now when we do that it's going to bisect
the base and let's just call this length
just this part here x and this part over
here x so here what we have to do is a
little bit of trigonometry to find out
what this piece is here so we're going
to say opposite and adjacent is tangent
so we're going to say the tangent of 36
degrees
is equal to the opposite side x over the
adjacent side 4. now all we have to do
is multiply both sides by 4
to get X by itself so let's go to the
calculator on that one make sure you're
in degrees and 4 tangent 36 comes out to
about
2.906 okay we'll just carry it out a
little bit so 2.906
and what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to double that
to get the length of one of these sides
so if I multiply this by 2 this is
actually going to come out to 5.812
and then if I multiply it by five sides
that's going to give us the perimeter so
let's multiply that by 5. so it looks
like our perimeter now
is going to be
let's see
29.062 so
29.062 we've got our apothem which we
said was 4.
and if we multiply all that together
let's see times 0.5 times 4 we should be
getting approximately an area of
58.12 inches squared
and that's your area now what I try to
do when I do these problems just a
little hint is
I like to kind of carry forward those
numbers so if you can use the previous
answer key and carry forward that long
decimal and I try to save rounding for
the very end to get a little bit more
accurate if you keep rounding each time
you'll be off a little bit it's like a
rounding error and you keep rounding
rounding like that it throws you a
little bit off so try to carry as much
of that decimal forward let's take a
look at example number three
okay before we dive into example number
three if you enjoy my content here on
YouTube and you find yourself coming
back to my videos now and again consider
supporting the channel by joining as a
channel member it really helps me out
and I appreciate it so let's uh jump
into example number three here uh
basically what we're given is a regular
decagon which means it has 10 sides
right and it's inscribed inside a circle
with radius eight meters now what does
this mean inscribed well scribe means to
draw right and it's on the inside and
you can think about this as the circle
as being circumscribed or drawn around
the polygon like this and so when we
talk about the radius we're really
talking about this Dimension right here
from the center to a point on the circle
or a vertex of the polygon so this is
our radius R right there so here what
I'm going to do is I'm going to just
draw one of these triangles of our
decagon so if I was to kind of
illustrate like this say this is just
one of the triangles imagine you had 10
of them okay all the way around this
okay continuing like that we need to
find out what this central angle is so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take 360 degrees
divided by 10 okay and that's going to
give us the central angle of 36 degrees
now we're going to drop an altitude okay
which remember we call that the apothem
and that's going to bisect this central
angle of 36 degrees cutting it in half
that's 18 degrees
now what we need to do is we need to
figure out what the apothem is we also
need to find out what this side length
is here so that we can find the
perimeter so let's start off by finding
the apothem now one thing I like to do
sometimes when I'm doing these problems
is you know write down the formula and
then kind of substitute in what I know
so I can kind of see what I'm still
missing what I need to go and find so in
this case let's go after the apothem
first
and what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to go ahead and use some
trigonometry so if we're here at this
angle 18 degrees we need the adjacent
and the hypotenuse that's our cosine
right so let's write that down we've got
the cosine of 18 degrees
is equal to adjacent which is a over
hypotenuse 8.
if we multiply both sides by 8
we can get that apothem by itself so
here I think what I'm going to do is
let's go ahead and get a decimal
approximation this is a 8 cosine 18.
okay which is about 7.61 or I'm just
going to actually write in here 8 cosine
18 and we'll multiply it at the very end
this way we'll get a little bit more
accurate okay and then for the perimeter
let's go ahead and figure out what this
side is here we're going to use the
opposite and the hypotenuse which is our
sine so we're going to say that the sine
of 18
is equal to X over 8. so opposite over
hypotenuse here if we multiply both
sides by 8 you can see that's going to
give us X but then we're going to have
to double it right because we have
you know this is just half of one side
length so we're going to double it and
we're also going to have to multiply by
10 because we have 10 side lengths so
it's really like multiplying by 2 and
then multiply 10 that's like multiplying
by 20. so this is really going to be
20 times 8 sine 18.
and that's going to be what our
perimeter is so if we multiply all that
together now let's see we've got 0.5
which is a half times eight cosine 18.
let's see times 20 times 8 is 160 sine
of 18
and it looks like we're getting now
approximately 188
.09 meters squared
so that's the area of this regular
decagon if you want to see some more
examples I'll put a video right there
where I talk more about finding out the
area of regular polygons follow me over
there and we'll get some more practice